[Musique]
et bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro du
débrief du dock retour sur le
documentaire beyrouth après l'enfer
récit des jours qui ont suivi la double
explosion survenue le 4 août dernier
dans un entrepôt du port de la capitale
libanaise y étaient stockés 2700 tonnes
de nitrate d'ammonium sont 70 morts près
de 6500 blessés et des dégâts matériels
considérables à les associations sont
alors sur le pied de guerre pour venir
en aide aux sinistrés parmi elles
l'association grenobloise sos attitude
et son président john dick ça bonjour et
merci de témoigner sur rt france
racontez nous comment arrivez vous sur
place à beyrouth
deux explosions ont lieu le 4 août en
fin de journée et nous sommes arrivés
deux jours et demi après du fait qu'il
fallait faire un test pvr un pcr
collègues avant de pouvoir prendre
l'avion
donc nous sommes arrivés dont la journée
du vendredi 7
quand vous arrivez à beyrouth à quoi
ressemble à gilles on a parlé de dégâts
matériels considérables à des centaines
de kilomètres à la ronde est ce que vous
aviez déjà vu de telles scènes lors de
vos précédentes missions malheureusement
oui
mais la particularité de beyrouth
c'était ce qu'on appelle l'unité de lieu
tout se passait dans un périmètre urbain
très restreint et la dernière fois que
je mets une chose pareil c'était en 2010
lors de grand grand tremblement de terre
à port au prince haïti mais
particulièrement dans le beyrouth ce que
nous a frappés c'était la densité
urbaine des dégâts alors on a tout de
suite regardé à quoi ressemble beyrouth
quelques heures après ce drame
extrait de ce documentaire beyrouth
après l'enfer
[Musique]
bravo mais je monte je
après l'explosion qui a frappé la ville
de beyrouth
le gouvernement a déclaré l'état
d'urgence pour deux semaines
les secouristes sont toujours en train
de passer au crible les débris à la
recherche de survivants
mais le plus grand nombre de morts a été
recensé dans le port
les habitants de la ville se rassemblent
attendant désespérément des nouvelles de
leurs proches disparus des centaines de
personnes sont toujours portées
disparues
la cause de l'explosion a été rapidement
déterminer environ deux mille sept cent
cinquante tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium
stocké dans le port ont explosé ils ont
été confisqués en 2014 aux navires rose
us pendant six ans cette substance se
trouvaient dans un entrepôt portuaire
sans aucune mesure de sécurité le chef
du service libanais des douanes a
déclaré que son agence avait demandé à
plusieurs reprises à la justice
l'autorisation de détruire la substance
dangereuse mais aucune mesure n'a été
prise
vous arrivez donc sur place à à beyrouth
avec votre équipe du matériel de
l'équipement quelle est alors la
priorité l'urgence de l'urgence c'est
déjà de se réunir avec d'autres
structures qui étaient déjà sur place
là le fait de ne pas pouvoir être partie
de suite pour les thèses coville nous a
permis de vraiment des blés le terrain
de pouvoir arriver sur place et on est
arrivés une demi heure sur place et on a
déjà rencontré notre groupe de travail
notre task force comme on dit qui est
comporté une demi douzaine de structures
et c'est avec 7 assez fort ce que nous
avons déterminé notre plan d'action
immédiat dans les 24 heures qui allait
venir
c'est à dire des évaluations de terrain
au coeur de la destruction tout près du
port de beyrouth
alors là vous êtes dans le récit assez
technique d'une mission humanitaire
finalement assez classique mais qu'est
ce que vous ressentez vous on est quand
même à beyrouth une capitale libanaise
très structuré très organisée là c'est
le chaos oui c'est le chaos total
ce qui m'a frappé le premier le premier
chose qui m'a frappé c'est l incapacité
d'ailleurs de se rendre en véhicule dans
le centre de beyrouth en fin de compte
on beyrouth tout les hôtes étaient
bloquées et gens c'est de la moitié du
verre lui monde entier sur les trottoirs
donc c'était il n'y avait plus aucune
maison bâtiments immeubles qui avaient
des fenêtres
donc c'est la chose qui m'a frappé le
plus ces thèmes la quantité du débris
verre partout il faut aussi donc reloger
les habitants
comment est-ce qu'ils réagissent ces
libanais quel a été votre ressenti on a
fait état d'une vraie solidarité parmi
les habitants de beyrouth
j'ai deux points à dire sur ce que vous
venez de dire on a su tout de suite
le lendemain on annoncé trois cent mille
personnes sans abri allô t'es un peu
surpris qu'on puisse avoir de telles
informations si rapidement et se place
deuxième chose qui nous a frappé c'était
le manque de personnes sans abri dont
les rues d'habitude en une catastrophe
de cette ampleur
on voit des gens dormir dans des abris
de fortune dans les rues près des
maisons etc et nous avons déduit qu
effectivement que peut-être que ce
n'était pas notre mission puisque envoyé
personne dehors bien sûr que les maisons
avaient été fracassées détruites au
beaucoup mais il y avait une solidarité
c'est la deuxième point que vous avez
évoquées mais la solidarité immédiate de
la part des libanais soit d'héberger ce
qui était mal en point
ou bien de déblayer les maisons des gens
qui étaient vraiment frappé par cette
catastrophe
donc oui quelque chose que j'ai jamais
vue auparavant c'était une solidarité
sans faille immédiate de l'ensemble des
libanais que j'ai pu côtoyer cette
intervention au niveau évidemment pas la
première pour vous pourquoi est ce que
cette fois ci c'était important de vous
retrouver aux côtés des sinistrés dans
cette capitale libanaise
notre association a pour vocation on est
tous bénévoles mais a pour vocation
d'être au plus près au plus vite
lors de catastrophes naturelles ou
autres et bien sûr le liban l'explosion
kahn a vu c'était phénoménal n'avais
jamais vu une chose pareille je pense
que le monde entier jamais vu une chose
pareille et nous avons toujours à coeur
d'aller dans n'importe quel pays quelle
que soit ce pays nous et non pas
d'ailleurs les payer nous aidons les
personnes frappées
or des catastrophes et en avaient envie
tout de suite quand on est venu ça le
soir même et le lendemain quand on a vu
les dégâts
waouh on a décidé de partir sur le
chemin tome pour apporter notre pierre à
la contribution de l'aide humanitaire
d'urgence et le liban pendant s'cusez
moi le liban bien sûr nous avons des
liens historiques et est très affectueux
avec les libanais et c'est un milieu que
l'on connaît bien professionnellement
également est ce que votre association a
reçu des dons pour venir en aide au
liban comment est ce que vous avez pu
financer votre mission à beyrouth
la particularité de notre association
c'est que on a des stocks de tentes et
de lampes que nous avons constitué bien
avons bien sûr nos interventions
donc ne sont prêts à partir avec des
ressources dans les heures qui suivent à
une catastrophe bien sûr nous nous
recevons des dons qui viennent des
personnes qui ont conduit nos actions
par exemple sur l'immédiat mais la
plupart de nos fonds sont des fonds
propres
nous faisons beaucoup d'interventions
par exemple dans les entreprises pour
collecter des fonds pour pouvoir partir
en mission mais nous avons également un
soutien de la fondation schneider
electric qui nous permet de financer un
stock de tentes tous les ans et ce
depuis cinq ans
donc ces deux sources d'argent nous
permettent d'être prêt à partir à tout
moment dans son importe quel continent
du monde
le drame survient au centre de cette
population déjà très affaibli avant la
catastrophe par une crise économique
sérieuse
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment une
fois que vous arrivez sur place que ces
coups de massue pour les libanais oui à
vrai dire si je suis honnête je ne
voyais pas je savais pas qu'il y avait
une difficulté économique dans le pays
j'ai appris ça quand je suis arrivé sur
place et il y à peu près un nom
effectivement il y avait une très très
grosse très grande crise économique dans
le pays
iman dit il avait un genou à terre le
coc vide enfin remis de deuxième genou à
terre et ces explosions c'était un un
coup de grâce c'était quelque chose très
très compliqué et nous avons
effectivement quelque chose que je
voudrais partager avec vous nous avons
rencontré beaucoup dérangé beaucoup de
personnes dont no dijo sur place et
quelqu'un m'a raconté et tous les autres
ont raconté ceci par la suite que depuis
la crise dire non
toute la classe moyenne au liban sont
devenus des classes moins fortunés
plutôt pauvre et que depuis un an il
avait du mal déjà à faire la
bienfaisance auprès des populations
démunies du pays et ce qu'ils
craignaient c'était effectivement ces
explosions mettre carrément le pays tout
entier à terre et qu'ils n'allaient pas
s'en remettre
aujourd'hui plus de deux mois après le
drame quels sont les besoins avec août
je pense que le premier souci c'est la
réhabilitation du port tout passe par le
porte parole peut pas envoyer des
hélicoptères des avions des équipements
c'est trop lourd c'est très complexe et
je pense que les industriels avec qui
nous sommes en contact
parce que nous avons quand même un très
bon réseau ils disent il faut
réhabiliter le port il faut réhabiliter
tous les systèmes électriques
déjà avant les explosions les libanais
avec dumas la voix de l'électricité de
manière constante
aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus compliqué
mais je pense que la chose la plus
compliquée actuellement pour les
libanais c'est la dévaluation à outrance
de la livre libanaise tout s'achète en
dollars lorsque nous sommes arrivés pour
notre et chance par exemple un dollar
valait 7500 livres libanaises
il y a un nom ça va les 1500 livres
libanaises donc la complexité pour
libérer aujourd'hui à mes yeux ça va
être
comment acheter des choses dont on a
besoin tous les jours avec un argent
d'évaluer à outrance à mon avis c'est
beaucoup plus un souci économique au
niveau des familles et insu ces
structures
au niveau des gouvernements est ce que
vous avez prévu de retourner
prochainement à beyrouth ou bien votre
mission est elle terminée
non c'est toujours repartir nous devons
repartir
déjà pour montrer la solidarité avec
ceux qui sont restés dans leur pays bien
sûr mais sur le terrain c'est compliqué
dans avec le co vide mais devant aller
également pour regarder ce que nous
avons fait tirer des enseignements là
dessus est dit est ce que la prochaine
fois que nous nous trouvons dans cette
situation on pourrait faire quelque
chose différemment au mieux ou plus
rapidement donc nous sommes dans un
éternel remise en question de manière à
plus loin
aider les plus de personnes de la
meilleure façon que ce soit dans
l'avenir merci beaucoup de jeunes dit
que ça pour votre un témoignage rappelle
que vous êtes président de l'association
sos attitude merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis vous pouvez revoir sa numéro du
débrief du doc sur notre site internet
rt france point tv à plus tard
[Musique]